It truly is an honor to be a part
of what God has been doing here what he is doing here. And
what I believe he's going to do here. It is a sweet
thing for us to have been apart for
the last five years and we're thankful for the time away that the
church does care for us in that as
we look forward to that. But we have more important things to focus on
today. So I want you to open your copy of
God's word and turn to the book of Acts with me Acts chapter
the book of Acts chapter 1
As you turn there, I want to start by telling you of one of my earliest memories
in my life.
It is my first day of preschool at
The Learning Tree in Enid, Oklahoma.
It was just etched into my mind. Like I can still
feel it. It was just me and my mom.
I'm sure she tried to to prep me
on how this was gonna go, but I guess it didn't work.
Because I remember I remember
going into the building and then walking down some stairs
into a room that for some reason was really dark. I
think it was a dungeon, but that's just me.
There were a few other kids in the room and probably some other parents Milling about
and I'm sure the teacher came over and said something to me, but all
that's just kind of blurry because the picture that's
burned into my mind.
Is is the backlit silhouette
of my mom as she walks out of
the room?
Dark, I can see let's just that it's like I can I can
see it in my head right now. And then I just I just
lost it.
I could feel it right now almost to my soul.
And go to my counselor next week and talk about that one.
Here's the thing though as you and I
know.
What I experienced that morning is part of
what it means to grow up.
See I needed to learn that first. I could
trust my mom was going to come back at the end of
the day.
But also that I had what I needed to thrive
in that environment that I've been left in.
I didn't know it at the time but God had prepared me. My
mom had prepared me for that moment.
And I was ready.
I start with that story because today we're going to talk about the Ascension of
Jesus Christ.
Last week and we talked about Christ's death and Resurrection.
But then what happened next?
Like what happened after that?
again that important too
and why why did that all happen? We need to know these things.
See after Jesus had lived 33 years
of life that we couldn't live.
After he died the death that we deserved.
And after he came back from the grave to defeat sin
and death for us.
40 days later. He just left.
He ascended back to heaven.
And I'm sure that the friends he left behind.
Felt a little like I did that August morning and Enid.
Where I was wondering if my mom would come back and if everything was going to
be all right.
That's why what we study today is so critical.
See if we can truly understand what we're talking about today. I
believe our day-to-day lives will be transformed.
I believe everything will change for us and here's a simple truth.
I hope we walk away understanding today. I try to keep it a
little memorable in some ways. But here's the truth.
I hope you can grasp today that every Christian can
live a faithful Life by
trusting in Christ and in his ascended power.
That's what I believe. That's what God's word shows us.
Is that every Christian?
can
Live a faithful Life by trusting in Christ and in
his ascended power.
My hope today.
Is that you gain some confidence from God's word?
that you see this that you you can
have confidence as you wait for his return Yes, but
also confidence as you live in
a chaotic world like we live in
that's what I hope you see today and we'll
see it in Acts chapter 1 first thing we need to do here is we need
to get the facts of his Ascension.
Like what even happened? How does this even work? What are the
facts the basic facts of his Ascension?
Look at verses 1 through 3 of chapter one to start
with.
In the first book oath Theophilus. I've dealt with all that Jesus
began to do and teach.
Until the day when he was taken up after he had given
commands through the Holy Spirit to the apostles whom he had
chosen.
He presented himself alive to them after his
suffering his cross by many proofs appearing
to them during 40 days and speaking about
the kingdom of God.
So this is the Doctor Luke who's researching The Life of
Christ and and his research indicated what Jesus did
during those 33 years of life. Yes, but
but Luke then also reiterated what we see later
in First Corinthians 15 where it says that in those
40 days post-resurrection over 500
people saw Jesus.
Like they talked to him. They ate meals with him that he was not just
a figment of people's imagination.
He was there.
He was risen.
And so he was teaching his disciples about the kingdom through those
40 days. The problem was at the disciples as they heard
Jesus talk about this kingdom of God. They
still did not have a full understanding of what he meant
by it. What was about to happen?
Like they assumed this moment as he's risen from the
grave this moment was when Jesus would take over now if he
is the Messiah he's going to take over they even asked that
in verse 6. Look at this.
When they'd come together, they asked him asked
Jesus Lord, will you at this time restore the
kingdom to Israel?
In other words Jesus is this going
to be the time that you bring the theocracy back?
Like you make it the way it used to be back in the old like we
read about with with Dave is this is this gonna be again when
you do that?
Now they weren't necessarily wrong.
They just had a very limited and Earthly focus on God's
actions at this time.
And so Jesus says to them know that's not what I came for at
this point in history. Look at verses 7 and 8.
He said to them it's not for you to know times or Seasons that
the father has fixed by his own authority.
But you will receive power when the Holy
Spirit has come upon you and you will be my Witnesses in
Jerusalem and all Judea and Samaria and to
the end of the Earth.
So the disciples came to Jesus looking for a calendar and he
gave them a commission.
Now we talk about that Acts 1:8 commission a
lot right that mission
is is at the very core of this whole thing. We
call Christianity. It's not just Christians and then
we have a mission like Christianity is a mission.
That's why we say around here. We say live sin. We
say you are sent we say it all the time around here
because we find later in the New Testament. We
are his ambassadors. We are ministers of reconciliation that
he's given us this charge to go.
But as soon as he gave those final words
in verse 8, look at what happened in verse 9
and when he had said these things as they were looking on
he was lifted up in a cloud took
him out of their sight.
Just think about how stunning that
would have been right?
You might have joined in with the disciples look at
verse 10 and while they were gazing into heaven
as he went, right? They're just they're just standing
there gawking like you remember the cartoons where
the mouth just drops to the floor. Like, that's the Imagine scene.
I have of this that they're just staring up in heaven.
Like what just happened?
I think we need to give him a break though, right?
Like this dude, just sitting there talking to them and then he just starts floating
and he goes up to heaven. They can't see anymore like
that would be stunning.
You wouldn't really know what to do in response. So natural.
They're just staring up into heaven. They don't know what to do with this.
till verse 10 continues behold
two men stood by them in white robes to
angels and said men of Galilee. Why do you stand looking
into heaven?
I got your answer Angels. Did you not just see what
happened here?
Why do you stand looking into heaven notice why they say it this Jesus
who was taken up from you into heaven will come
in the same way as you saw him go into
heaven.
So the apostles are staring there like a like
a kid at a zoo seeing a giraffe for the first time just
staring up into heaven.
But then these angels show up and say hey guys. Listen, this
is not the end.
What you just watched happen will happen someday in
Reverse when he comes back.
Meaning he is returning one day and what's he
coming back to do we know from the rest of scripture. He's coming back to put an end
to evil and to suffering and to fully and
finally bring about his kingdom here on Earth. That's what he's
coming back to do.
That's good news.
Now we think about this scene though.
The reality is that Jesus hypothetically could
have stayed and inaugurated his
kingdom then right?
He could have taken over like they asked him to take over, but
he didn't.
He left and and so so there must
be a purpose to him leaving and us staying
here.
Even like when we get converted when we repent and
believe and God changes our lives, he doesn't just poof us to heaven. So there's a
reason we are still here a reason those apostles were left there.
Well, that's next. We saw the facts of the rest of
the Ascension now, we need to understand the implications of
his Ascension.
Why did he do it?
Why did this happen the way it did the implications
here?
Follow up to that is what did Jesus ascend back to heaven to do?
Why did he leave? Yes any implications of that for us? But but
what's he even doing in heaven right now?
Let's see send it back to heaven. So what's he doing? Is he chilling
on a cloud like like hanging out with Moses playing golf
on perfect Fairways like singing in the quiet. We don't
what is Jesus doing right now?
Listen, I hope.
I hope you get some encouragement here from this one Church like
this this right here. What is Jesus doing right
now man this
This I hope fills us up because first
scripture says when he went to heaven.
He sat down at the right hand of God.
Now why is that even important?
Why does it matter where he's sitting?
Because the right hand of the king.
Signifies honor signifies Authority
is signifies power.
Jesus even predicted this about himself Luke 22 69.
He's he's talking to the counsel. He's
in a trial moment in this and and he said
to them from now on you will see the son of man that's
his character designation of himself. It's the
son of man shall be seated at the right hand of the power
of God.
See that there's there's power in that
position. He has it's also in the Great Commission Matthew
28:18. Jesus said after his resurrection, all
authority in heaven on
Earth has been given to me.
He's got power. He's got Authority even further Paul
picks this up in Ephesians chapter 1 verses 20 through
23 that he worked in Christ when he
raised him from the dead seated him at his right hand
in the Heavenly places far above all Rule and
authority and power and Dominion above every name
that his name not only in this age, but also in the
one to come he put all things under his feet gave him
his head over all things to the church, which is his body
the fullness of him who fills all in all
I say all of that simply to say this that Jesus is the
king.
Like this this is who he is. I know
I know it's hard to understand how his sovereignty works out day
to day and you're thinking well, he's the king how come this bad
stuff? I know that's hard.
But the other worldly Kingdom has a
king.
Remember last week. Jesus says my kingdom is not of this world.
This other worldly Kingdom has a king. His name is Jesus
who is good who does good and there are no
competitors to his throne.
So what does Jesus doing right now? He's reigning as the king
that alone should give us confidence today,
right?
But he's not only ruling Over All.
Eventually bringing his kingdom in full one day.
He's ruling but first Timothy 2:5 says Jesus is also mediating
between us and the father.
What's Jesus doing right now? He's ruling he's mediating.
What's a mediator?
A mediator is a go-between.
A person who attempts to make unreconciled people
come to a peaceful agreement together.
That's what a mediator's goal is and that is
what Jesus is doing for you and for me right now
Christian.
Like he's an attorney who is defending us
against the enemy's accusations.
Tossing all these things against us and he's he's
defending us but he's also the one
who paid the penalty the judge is demanding.
So the judge said here's what has to happen. You're guilty. Yes.
But he stepped in between and said no. I'm going to take the penalty
instead.
He's mediating and that's just constantly happening.
He's given himself for our penalty.
So if we have Jesus mediating for
us, that's how we can draw near in confidence.
We can draw near to God in full Assurance knowing
that our sins are covered.
That we are forgiven.
Christian
please hear that today.
Stop judging yourself for what Jesus has already
paid for cleansed and washed away.
You are forgiven.
You have a mediator you have one who paid
the price continually claims it
for you in the courtroom of Eternity. He is
in your place.
You are forgiven.
I know you you might regret there might be some consequences from what you've
done but you're not a second-class citizen in the
Kingdom of Heaven.
You're forgiven.
Don't walk back into it, but you're forgiven live in that
today.
So he's ruling he's mediating. There's
even more he's doing right now.
John 14
one through three says this
Jesus let not your hearts be troubled.
believe in God believe also in me
in my father's house are many rooms if
it were not so what I have told you that I go to
prepare a place for you.
And if I go and prepare a place for you, I will come again and we'll
take you to myself that where I
am. You may be also.
So like many of us sang growing up.
G one thing Jesus is doing right now is he's preparing
a big big house.
With lots and lots of rooms.
It's got a big table in it.
Got a big yard, you can play football. For
example.
That's what he's doing right now. Who's he
building the house for he's building a house for his children.
For those who trusted in him?
And I know life is hard.
It's hard for all of us in various ways. But
the good news here is that he's prepared. He's gone
to prepare a place. So we're kind of sad about that. But also
the king is coming back for his children.
If I go to prepare a place I'm going to come back for you. That's what he says.
So he's preparing this future home for us right
now.
There are more things I could mention that Jesus doing right now. He's he's fighting
the spiritual battle behind the scenes.
He's praying for us every moment. Like
these are things that we must remember Jesus doing for
us. But I hope you can see even just this small glimpse. Why?
Every Christian can live a faithful Life As
We Trust in Christ and in his ascended power.
In what he's doing for us right now. That's how we can
walk in confidence. That's how we can stand strong when we
look at this. If you are his you can stand strong
knowing he reigns over all that. He has forgiven
you and that one day he's coming back to
get you.
That's today. You can stand strong today
no matter what you face.
So that's what he's doing, but there's a flip side to this.
That he left to go do some things. Yes.
But it's also true that he then left us
here to do something as well.
Not to just merely survive, but to to do
something as well. We saw what Jesus doing, but what are we supposed
to do since he left?
He didn't take us with him.
So what are we supposed to do until he comes back to get us?
Well, first of all, it's
to repent and believe
right that
that's the core of this he wants us to
turn from our sin and our self and turn to Jesus life death
and Resurrection in our place. That's the core of
all of this.
What do we do until he comes back? We are called to repent
and believe.
It all starts there.
But then think about how the early church responded to this
moment in Acts.
Jesus ascended to Heaven. How did
the early church respond to
him? How did how did their lives change in
response now that they knew he was
resurrected and they knew he was ascended in all
authority that he had in that. What did they do?
Well, they became these acts 18
Witnesses.
That's the entire rest of the book of Acts is them living out?
What Jesus just said to do his last words were their
first priority? That's what they began to do.
Remember, what a witness is.
a witness
Is simply saying what they know what
they've seen?
There's no debate. There's no angle. There's there's
no one that can argue against your
your story your your witness your
testimony, right? It's your story.
Just think about the blind man. Jesus healed
in John chapter 9.
If you don't know the story that the scene is that the Pharisees heard
about Jesus healing this man. They bring the man
before the council they begin to question him. They're trying
to catch him in a lie. They even bring his parents in to say
is he really blind from birth or was that just a store? Like they're trying
to figure out how they can trap this guy and eventually trapped
Jesus as a result, but here's the thing.
They could not deny the fact that this man
was healed.
In fact, this is one of my favorite passages in scripture
in John 9:25. The man says this
like they're debating trying to get him to say something wrong
and in chapter 9 verse 25, they're talking
about Jesus negatively. And this is what he says.
Whether he is a sinner, I don't know one thing. I do know
that though. I was blind now I can see.
I you guys can think whatever you think about this guy. If
you think he's a profit you think he's a sinner whatever it is all I
know I've been blind my whole life and now I can see.
That's green. That's blue. I can tell that's like
you you see I can see now I couldn't see
before so he did something.
That's the point of a testimony, right?
You talk about how your life has changed and no one can deny
the fact that you were this and now you're this.
That's your story. No one can debate that.
But listen we get so excited about all kinds
of things. We get really excited about like like how
we lost weight or or what our favorite side hustle
is that we're making money this way or or how
our favorite team is playing or not. They're playing very well at
all like you we get super excited. We talk about all those things.
Why do we not get more excited about what God
has done in our lives?
We talk about this we post about this. We say all
these things. Why do we not get more excited? Like how could we not want to
tell people that Jesus has saved Our Lives
eternally.
That we have been saved that we actually oh
God.
We actually know God because not because we
made our way to him, but because he came to us in grace
and mercy and so we know God as a result of him
initiating this whole thing.
How can we not get excited about that see when we're truly
awakened to that reality?
Living like that and talking like that doesn't feel like
an obligation anymore.
It's done out of love.
It's done out of reverence. It's done out of all.
for how great our God is
I know you I've grown up in my whole life in church
and you've heard it over and over again. We need to go share the gospel. We need to go love people.
We need to these things and it kind of feels obligation.
I guess I got to remember to do that this week sometime right down
to store like no.
listen, if
if you are awake to the reality of
Jesus dying in your place.
Of him loving you enough that you were an enemy made you
a family like if you've been awakened to that the gratitude that
just compels us to talk about it.
Changed our lives. We must speak. It's
like it's like when the council commanded Peter
and John.
to not speak about Jesus in Acts 4:20
They brought him in and they said hey, you guys need to stop talking
about this Jesus.
their response
we cannot help but speak of
what we've seen and heard.
we have to
You can kill us we have to talk about this.
Because he is God who came to us
as our savior?
Just be awaken to that reality Church.
Now I know I get it.
When we start to consider this Acts 1:8 commission that
Jesus says to be witnesses to All Nations. It's
daunting.
Start to think how How would how do I need to respond to
that? I mean, I'm
All Nations, I can't even travel I can't I
don't go very far. How can I be a witness to the
nation? Am I disobedient to God or or you begin to think about how unqualified you
are or how unprepared you
are for this or you're afraid of what people gonna think about you if
you start really living this thing out and and so you see all
of that makes it really daunting.
To do what God's left us here to do.
Which is why we must understand how?
We are to go about this task.
Seeing what Jesus is doing.
What we are to do.
How do we do it?
How do we go about this task?
Well, you might have noticed that I skipped in Acts
1 verses 4 and 5 the first time.
Acts 1 verses 4 and 5 look at that now.
While staying with them he ordered them not to
depart from Jerusalem, but to wait for the promise
of the father.
Which he said you heard from me for John baptized with
water, but you will be baptized with the
Holy Spirit not many days from now.
And then in verse 8 I read early but he ties the mission
with the Holy Spirit look at this, but you
will receive power.
When the Holy Spirit has come upon you and you will
be my Witnesses in Jerusalem and Judea Samaria
and to the end of the Earth.
So I know you look at this commission Global and
and
challenging and you're gonna have stick stick your neck
out a little bit all that you look at that and it is overwhelming. And yes.
Hear me say this every single one of us is
inadequate for that task.
That's where we all are.
But here's one final major implication of
Christ's Ascension.
It's that the Holy Spirit comes into every believer.
Now this is not the first time the Holy Spirit shows up in the Bible.
Holy spirit's been present and active from before creation all
the way through the Old Testament. He was just selective
as he came and went on people for
certain tasks and purposes.
the difference now
is that all believers have the Holy
Spirit indwelling them?
and it happens first here in Acts chapter 2
the Holy Spirit comes on the first Christian. Jesus said wait till he's
gonna come in a couple days. Well a couple days later.
It's called Pentecost and you're gonna see that in a few weeks and Acts chapter
2. We'll get there at the end of May.
But he comes on them to empower them
to obey Christ's commands here this one
but all of the other ones.
We see in Acts 2. They received the Holy Spirit, they're filled
and they're obedient, but it's the same thing. It's
also what happens for every Christian at conversion.
Where the Holy Spirit fills you to empower you
to fulfill Christ's call also.
It's not just an acts two thing. This is for you and
me as well.
Yet if we're being honest.
If we had a choice.
Most of us would prefer Jesus to
still be here.
Where Jesus be walking around talking to people like we
could invite him to be the guest preacher over the next few weeks. That'd be
pretty cool.
but listen to what Jesus says
John 16 verse 7. He says it is
to your advantage that I go away.
For if I do not go away the helper.
Critical word the helper will not come to you.
But if I go.
I will send him to you.
You see what that means.
The condition on the Holy Spirit coming into
the life of every believer was that Jesus
had to leave.
We want Jesus right here. No, he had to leave so that this
could happen and Jesus said that would actually be better for us.
How's that better?
Because then not only is God beside you you have
God inside you.
As Acts 1:8 says you will remember you
will receive power.
When the Holy Spirit has come upon you.
And the holy spirit's not different 2,000 years later. It's the
same Holy Spirit the same power that lives in you
believer.
And hear me when I say empowering here that simply means
God gives you the ability to do what he's called
you to do.
Which by the way when we say empowering for that, it means way
more than just preaching or moving overseas.
Empowering here means you're empowered
to serve it Camp to serve at VBS to
Mentor a young mom.
It's empowered to go on mission trips. It's empowered
to minister to your neighbors.
It's empowered to get plugged into a micro group with just a few other people
here in this church. It's empowered to
pray diligently for the lost and for the ministry of
the church. That's what we're talking about here.
and way more
it's also God empowering you to overcome that temptation.
It's God empowering you to sacrificially love your spouse
when you want to be selfish.
it's got empowering you to step up and
lead out when there's a need at work and nobody else is
going to fill it, but you can
And it's God empowering our church.
To fill the call of God has on us to glorify him by
becoming this hub for an all ages disciple making movement where
we see lives transformed all over the place that that's God's
power through his holy spirit in us to do
those kinds of things.
So my mom walked out of that room that morning.
I could have run to the corner and curled up and
cried the whole time until she came back.
But the essence of our faith.
You take that into this context. The essence of our faith is
not just surviving until Jesus comes.
It's actually able to thrive in
the environment that he has left us in here.
That we're not just scared in the corner until he comes back. We're
actually able to thrive how because he's planted his
holy spirit inside you believer.
You don't have to live scared in the corner. You can thrive in
this. So yes, I know the mission is daunting. I
know life is difficult life is painful. But
because Christ is ascended raining
ruling mediating all of those things. And because
he's planted his holy spirit inside of us. We can
have confidence to live a faithful life today and every
day
this is what enabled the church in Acts that
we look at and say wow amazing, right? This
is what enabled them to be. So mildly used
by God.
They're no different than we are.
The holy spirit's the same in them as it is in us.
They knew they lived as if
they knew that the only way they
could accomplish this mission is if God did it.
I already said earlier Peter and John boldly spoke before the council in
Acts chapter 4 but listen to The Believers prayer right
after that scene, they come back
and they're rejoicing they got persecuted. But listen to this acts 4:29
through 31. They pray now Lord
look upon their threats Grant to your
servants to continue to speak your word with all boldness.
While you stretch out your hand to heal
and signs and wonders are performed through the
name of your holy servant Jesus.
And when they'd prayed the place in which they were gathered together
was shaken and they were all filled with the Holy Spirit and
continued to speak the word of God with boldness.
You see how they had that kind of confidence.
How can we have that kind of confidence today? They
had it we can have it because they believed and we
believe in a Creator God who is supremely Sovereign
and who Reigns over all things as the king of
kings.
That's that's confidence building for us. We have
the King on the throne. But also
here's another reason confidence is because our enemy
is like a snake with his head cut off right? He's
still thrashes around and he fights hard. But ultimately
he's already defeated.
The death and resurrection and soon coming return of
Jesus Christ has defeated the enemy.
And again if you're in his family.
Through repentance and belief you have that
as your confidence and you have everything you
need to do what he's called you to do.
your king
has resourced you.
with his spirits power
He's given you his word.
He's given you his body the church.
So you and I and every believer can
live a Godly life.
possible
and we can fulfill his Commission.
It's possible.
and remember the
maybe maybe one of the best parts of this is that we can do all of
that with confidence we can thrive in this environment today.
Because like my mom did at the end of that school day.
We know our Master is coming
back to make it. All right again.
And so let's trust him today.
Let's live for him every day.
until that day
when it's all right again.
amen
Listen, I want you to remember something in this.
This only works.
this this only
works if we have been if you have been Justified
before God.
If you've been made right with God.
and thankfully
he has made the way for that to happen.
His broken body and shed Blood on the
cross is what makes the way.
for us
for Sinners Like Us.
That's what we remember and celebrate with the Lord's Supper.
Celebrating all that God has done all that he is doing and
really technically all that he will do.
So I'm going to invite the worship leaders to come back out now.
And if you're gonna serve the Lord's Supper elements, you can go ahead and come forward and
begin to set those things up.
If you need gluten-free, it's always at the back so you can go slip out and grab that.
But as they come get prepared and everything gets starting set it
up. I know we can kind of transition our minds, but I want you and
I to get
Prepared as well.
They're gonna get set up all of that. But we must remember
a couple things as we do this.
First that this is a reminder.
That we could not save ourselves.
Right. This act is a reminder. We cannot save ourselves we
needed Jesus to do it for us. His broken body shed blood is
what does it but it's also reminder that he did it.
we couldn't do it and he actually did it
his broken body and shed blood paid the price to cover our
sins forever and ever if we believe
That's why this is for believers who have declared that their faith
is in him publicly, but also believer remember he's
forgiven you.
He's forgiven you for all of this.
Walk in that rest in that today.
But this act is also a reminder.
That our response to God's work is to
die to ourselves and to give him everything.
That's what he deserves.
If this is who our King is, that's what he deserves all the time
every moment of every day. So mourn your
sin rejoice in his salvation and in that
give your life more and more.
to him